expressed her willingness and readiness
to help in any way possible
if there is a need that or a support
that the North Korea asks for Jamie
that's changed please and then we will
try to get a few questions from online
we are trying to sort out that the
conclusion is 40 to 70 percent of the
world's five billion adults could at
some point contract coronavirus I guess
I just wanted to know how it's really
that dire in your perspective and just
with that in mind could you also tell us
what you know more about what a
symptomatic transmission and whether or
not surfaces could be stab at the first
part Jamie yeah I mean we've had these
numbers almost every week now for for
the last eight weeks and we need to as
I've always said take each prediction
into account we need to know what data
that's based on this is usually based on
modeling data based on certain
assumptions about transmission and about
our north and though and some
assumptions about control measures are
not and certainly you can model with
control measures or model without
control measures so I'd like to see the
data and see what that prediction is
based on we will listen to all good
science having said that there are
obvious real things happening in the
real world that contradict us if we look
at as China today 20 provinces in China
have today downgraded their public
health emergency risk level it's 20 or
31 actually gone in the reverse they've
gone from red to yellow or from yellow
to green now that's flying in the face
of that prediction I'm not saying which
one is correct but I'm telling you in
the real world today
is moving back towards the green in
there in the 11 provinces in China today
moved to green which is their lowest
level of risk in the five levels of risk
on the 29th of January all provinces in
China were at level 1 risk the highest
possible risk red red the whole of China
was red
so there's hoping that today there were
only 4 cases of our yesterday last 24
hours only 4 cases of confirmed call
with 19 infection outside who Bay were
actually from China most cases outside
ube in China yesterday came from other
countries so when I look at that which
is happening in the real world and then
I look at predictions I need to look and
we need to look at both of those we need
to see what's happening in Singapore and
the DG is centered in a speech this is
another drill we need to fight we need
to fight now because our predictions
will come true if we do nothing at all
we have choices today there some
countries are stepping forward and
turning to face the fire and we need all
countries to do that right now second
part of that question this or the
question around a symptomatic
transmission and the role of surfaces so
we know that this is a respiratory
pathogen and it spreads through droplets
and so these droplets that come out of
our mouths and our noses if we call we
sneeze will move some distance and
they'll settle on surfaces and there are
some experimental studies that are
currently underway that are looking at
how long these viruses will survive on
different types of surfaces and some
preliminary results from that look like
this virus act behaves similar to the
SARS coronavirus
but those viruses can be inactivated
with disinfectants so cleaning of
surfaces can can can clear those viruses
away and that's that's important the
role of a symptomatic transmission
this is I understand why this is a very
important question it is a very
important question to us as well we know
that this infection with kovat 19 causes
a wide range of symptoms including
people who don't develop symptoms what
we understand for is that because
contact tracing is is so strong in some
countries cases that have not yet
developed symptoms are being identified
by PCR by being PCR positive and so
these are people who are pre-symptomatic
so it's a few days before they develop
symptoms now the question is whether or
not those individuals can can transmit
to other people we know that that is
possible but we do not believe that
that's a major driver of transmission
and the reason we know that is because
if we look at the actual epidemics and
how these epidemics are unfolding if
they were a major driver of transmission
we would it would have caused much
larger numbers of cases the big question
that we have right now is whether an
serology and looking at how many people
have been infected overall and how many
people are truly asymptomatic that is
how many people have been infected but
don't develop symptoms and those studies
are starting now there are sahaja Casas
that are in use right now we are
advocating for population-based surveys
to be conducted so that we can have a
better understanding of which proportion
of the population has evidence of
infection as as detected through through
antibodies but we do not believe that a
symptomatic transmission is a major
driver of transmission it's still early
days it's still a few weeks into this
outbreak we're learning every day
something new about this virus that can
change every every statistic everything
that we say here but based on the
evidence we're an evidence-based
organization we're taking the evidence
we received from countries we're looking
at all of the scientific papers that are
coming out and we're looking at the
evidence so right now and what we know
based on the evidence that asymptomatic
transmission is not a major driver of
transmission
[Music]
the DJ has spoken to this many times
that was the whole purpose of having the
joint WH o Goran international team join
our Chinese colleagues was to do exactly
that less that Lester's learned and let
me be clear
and I've been at this a long time nobody
has ever responded to an epidemic
perfectly no one has ever responded in
perfect time but the perfect response
this is the real world we live in every
every emergency response is dotted with
missed opportunities and unfortunate
delays and sometimes decisions that have
to be made unlimited data that
subsequently turn out you look back and
you think you know what if we knew that
now what we then what we knew now we
might have done something differently so
we need to be really careful and the one
hand to learn the lessons and on the
other hands not to say that exactly what
happens in China needs to now happen
exactly the same everywhere else the
issue is one of the lessons and the
lessons I think we've learned from
China's Singapore's to break down your
problem understand where you have just
sporadic cases understand where you have
clusters understand where you have
community transmission adapt your
response to those needs distribute your
resources according to priority be
persistence be consistent be
coordinators we joined up these are the
things we need to see command control
coordination coherence
and that the DG has been speaking to an
all of government approach community
society public sector private sector and
government coming together to work
together and in weeks and it's been
shown it can be turned around in weeks
if that is what people are prepared to
do now the DG a set of many times there
are no guarantees with that approach
there are no guarantees that that can be
achieved but at the very least that will
significantly slow down the spread of
this virus allowing our health systems
to catch up and I think all of you have
seen the health systems even some health
systems with a very small number of
cases have already struggled they've
already struggled to deal with the small
caseload so we need to get our health
systems stronger and one of the ways of
doing that is to slow down the spread of
this disease so containment and control
measures slow down the disease so but
it's really important that we don't turn
this into China was right about
everything and someone else is wrong
about everything or everyone else is
right and because there's been too much
of this on both sides we need to learn
the lessons that have been Africa Vaughn
because each new context is different
what we do in country X will not be the
same exactly of what you do in country Y
because the context is different the
evolution is different but there are
wonderful lessons we can learn from
China just wanted to say that one of the
things we've learned is that the
fundamentals work the fundamentals of
Public Health work the fundamentals of
identifying your case is identifying
your context I'm an epidemiologist this
is this is epidemiology at its core
uuugh you need to look for your cases
aggressively you need to find all of
those contacts and find those context
you need to mobilize your population one
of the things I was most touched at if I
could say in China was the absolute
drive of every single person we met
every person of the population knew what
their role was in this outbreak they
knew what they needed to do they knew
how they how they had to protect
themselves how they could protect their
family
and what they needed to do collectively
to bring this under control we've said
before it doesn't just because you have
cases doesn't mean you're gonna have
clusters doesn't mean you're gonna have
large outbreaks it doesn't mean that
it's gonna go out of control
we've seen not only in China we've seen
these fundamentals be being used in
Singapore being used in Vietnam being
used in many countries and they're
bringing that back down and it comes
back down to the fundamental these
fundamental public health measures and
that is something every country can do
Thank You Maria and thank you Mike I
just wanted to add there is a common
factor for all countries common which we
call political commitment or political
intervention as you know political
intervention it is like surgical
intervention it brings a paradigm and
meaning if the highest level of the
government the head of state or head of
government starts to lead and
coordinates all the sectors that brings
qualitative change in the way we respond
to the epidemic and that can be done by
any country on earth that can bring a
new paradigm in each and every country
that's why in my statement today we
focused on whole government approach no
government no country has an excuse
because each and every country has a
government and that's what we are asking
for check it to a higher level this is
not up to the ministers of health only
this is the responsibility of the head
of state the head of government and it
should be coordinated from the top and
all sectors should be involved this
virus is touching every thing in the
country it will in those countries that
is not his
there so that's why if it's going to
touch everything if it's going to take
the politics if it's going to take the
social fabric of the country if it's
going to tack touch the economy then no
sector is immune or untouched that's why
we are saying we have to raise it up and
then the political commitment is at the
center the political intervention is at
the center because that's the surgical
intervention that brings paradigm and I
was so you know encouraged to get a call
from president sebastián piñera of Chile
his own initiative calling and
discussing about what the situation is
the global and in his own corner also
and you know exchanging ideas on how we
can really beat this virus and not only
that we had a very good discussion this
was the day before yesterday with
President
Sebastian Pinera but today with the
prime minister of Sweden another
excellent discussion on the global
situation on the importance of whole
government approach by the way he was
just coming out of a meeting with this
cabinet discussing about this president
sebastián piñera but today with the
prime minister of Sweden another
excellent discussion on the global
situation on the importance of whole
government approach by the way he was
just coming out of meeting with his
cabinet discussing but this is president
trampy himself and also for regular
coordination designating the
vice-president these are the approaches
we are saying are derived
and these are the approach we're saying
are going to mobilize the whole
government but not only the whole
government but that whole government
should mobilize the whole society and
making the response every citizens
business if we do that we can push back
on this virus we can be successful in
the containing containment strategy some
people you're following the media are
saying it's already the pandemic you
know there is nothing we can do now we
should move into mitigation and
containment may not work we we don't
think that containment should be
abandoned because I have already saved
many countries are succeeding in that
strategy containment strategy and
containing the virus but we are not
saying just follow containment strategy
what we're saying is in addition to
aggressive containment strategy please
also prepare for any eventuality there
could be crisis in our hands
so let's prepare for any eventuality but
we should not give up on containment
strategy the worst thing that can happen
to any country or even any individual is
giving up so that nature is saying don't
give up don't surrender use
comprehensive approach
don't use dichotomy
let's use a comprehensive approach
everything that we can do to contain it
if not we won't say it then we will have
the other strategies at hand because we
are saying let's prepare for the rest so
that's what we are saying and this is
linked with the political commitment we
said this kind of approach comprehensive
approach cannot be sustained without
political sustainable political
commitment political commitment at the
highest level coordination at the
highest level political intervention I
repeat again political intervention is
surgical intervention it brings paradigm
that's what we believe and then of
course there should be technical
competence to you add both technical
competence and political commitment you
can get the highest and the biggest
impact you can many countries are
showing that now so it's not time to
give up let's go for a comprehensive
approach and that's our advice as whu-oh
course there should be technical
competence you add both technical
competence and political commitment you
can get the highest and the biggest
impact you can many countries are
showing that now so it's not time to
give up let's go for a comprehensive
approach and that's our advice as whu-oh
accountant on YouTube the audio is clean
let's try if we can get South China
Morning Post Karen Karen can you hear us
question four sentences genifique
transition has became two different
versions I suppose you've just mentioned
her damage it's a border again you said
we were not decorated any word for for
the thesis but it's a different type of
incidence in different countries if you
concern that we came to the Pagani which
will be covered or no covering any
countries for health issues two
different types of the virus yes so so
as as as you're aware you know many
sequences full genome sequences have
become publicly available thanks to to
authorities and scientists posting those
on publicly available sites so we
they're these genetic sequences have
been analyzed by a large number of
virologists and scientists across the
globe and whu-oh is working with a
network of scientists on this and there
are there when you do the phylogenetic
analysis of these we know that there are
some early clades that have have been
visible on the trees and the paper that
came out that you're referring to these
tree these divisions were seen on the on
this tree very early on it's an analysis
based on 103 full genome sequences and
they have no known association with
severity in terms of these differences
so you know looking at the file of
genetics as more sequences become
available and we encourage countries to
please make your full genome sequences
available so that these analyses can
continue but this virus is very stable
based on all of the sequences that we've
seen so far
this kind of genetic analysis is very
important for two reasons obviously one
it can help us in looking at the Z
spread because you can compare viruses
and spreads and try and link chains with
transmission and that's a race we were
using that right now in Congo we've been
using that well hopefully we won't have
to use it again as we've no more cases
but that's it's also useful for tracking
the development of vaccines and others
because you eventually have to pick us
backs a strain that you want a base a
vaccine on and you want it that's to be
the close as possible to what you have
circulating the the data that's been
published most recently has actually
been publicly available for weeks and
what's happening is researchers are
going back into those wonderful
resources that are now available and
asking questions and looking at these
two clades but I'd like it more to
license plates it's as if they've found
- exactly - two cars exactly the same
make of car but the license plates are a
little bit different is it a different
car no it's not a different carrots got
a slightly different signature but it's
not it's not fundamentally a different
virus and that's the most important
thing here but these please this is very
important that these inquiries still go
on and that's the wonderful thing about
having publicly accessible databases is
that researchers and others have access
to that data can question that data can
generate hypotheses can publish those
hypotheses we can discuss them in the
open but it's also very important that
we don't over interpret the results of
the conclusions of any single study and
I think that's the balance we need to
strike
I would start by saying I said it
earlier I'm very concerned especially
the past few days because more and more
cases are being reported from countries
with weaker health systems and that adds
to the concern that many are already
saying this could evolve into a pandemic
or some people say we are almost closed
and that could be true
I'm saying the situation I also agree
that the situation could be worse than
what we are now and it could be a
pandemic level but what at the same time
we are saying is there are countries
within this situation who have shown
that it can be contained so we should
not give up so we need to use a
comprehensive approach and we have also
said many times there is no like one
size fits all and if you see from
country to country there is variation
and even within one country there is
variation so unless we're convinced that
that is uncontrollable why do we call
that it's pandemic but I mean with with
flu we know it's uncontrollable and it
affects big part of the population
probably what percent to billion for
instance with with h1n1 if we reach into
that conclusion then it's uncontrollable
we may be able or we may be in a
position to say that but with what we
are saying is that's not that time that
may happen but we don't give up without
fighting hard that's what we are saying
those who fought hard
have already contained it so there is
already a positive signal and experience
within this virus itself so let's really
use the comprehensive approach and you
remember some countries have already
said we don't mind whether WH oh you
know says this is pandemic or not we
would like to continue with a
comprehensive approach including
aggressive containment and we said
you're right that's exactly what we are
saying that's exactly what we are saying
so if we don't we agree on the approach
which is a comprehensive approach then
the name may not matter but even the
name may matter and if we get there we
will say it no problem at all based on
science and evidence so that's what we
are saying but for now we're not yet
there although there are very very
concerning signs and this virus making
it into more and more countries with
weaker health systems but that doesn't
mean that we should give up we're saying
we shouldn't until the last attempt and
that's what we are advising and the
political commitment and political
intervention should be triggered in all
countries and try our best to contain it
that's what we are saying until the last
attempt and that's what we are advising
and the political commitment and
political intervention should be
triggered in all countries and try our
best to contain it that's what we are
saying
so we focus on saving lives we focus on
saving lives by treating cases or
developing a vaccine to protect the most
vulnerable in our population that's the
that's the approach in this case some
countries are demonstrating that it is
possible to control the spread it's
impossible it's possible to slow it down
and in that calculation you now have two
chances to save lives
if you contain and suppress the virus
you save lives by making sure that
vulnerable people in your society are
not exposed and then if they are exposed
you have time more time to get your
system ready to save their lives you get
another shot at life-saving intervention
so when the Director General speaks
about uncontrollable spread in which we
focus on saving lives versus
uncontrolled spread of what we do have
at the moment in some countries is a
situation where the disease has spread
and in some countries not under control
yet so ever it's not controlled or
uncontrolled but what he's saying is we
have a chance to control that and I
think it's a very very important
distinction of words and I really want
to second what he's saying and I think
it does explain a lot of the underlying
logic that we're using here around the
pandemic word thank you very much we
have time for one question we will try
to get that question from online because
we were not really able to do that and
we apologize for all those let's try one
more time with Karen from South China
Morning Post Karen can you hear us this
time hello yes I can yes I can hear me
hi my question is about pets as you know
and also you mentioned that the dog has
been tested weak positive and yesterday
the Hong Kong authorities announced at
the talk
like has low-level infection with the
coronavirus and so my question is do you
think that governments need to
quarantine the pets and monitor them
like the pets belong to the English page
thank you Karen that question already
came at the very beginning of the
briefing and I apologize if you were not
able to listen so maybe now you can just
like you know two words repeat yes we
are aware of the dog in Hong Kong that
tested positive and and as I mentioned
previously there's there's we're working
with our partners in Hong Kong at FAO
and
oh eyyy to really understand what this
means we do not believe that that having
pets infected or one pet infected as a
driver of transmission in this outbreak
but as Mike had said also that this is
not unprecedented to have this example
but again this is something that we're
working with our partners to better
understand an interesting you know the
authorities in in Hong Kong officially
reported that under the organization
indian internationale des epizootic Oh
ie so that's a nfa are actively tracking
that situation and we we've had
teleconferences with them and at this
point there is no need for any special
measures but follow-up studies are
underway but but certainly the care of
the animals is important and obviously
the any potential impact on disease
spread as we keep saying outliers and
unusual observations are very important
an epidemic response but we also need to
be careful to be sure that we don't
allow that to drive our thinking at its
core they need to influence what we do
and at the moment we don't believe
there's any need for a change in policy
based on the evidence we have but we
will continue to work with Hawaii to see
if there's a need for a change in our
public out the place so our first and
last questions was about pets and we
will conclude
here tomorrow is another day John and
the river will be here I thank everyone
for watching guys and apologies one more
time for all for those who had wanted to
ask question and they were not able so
hope hopefully we will be able to take
more questions tomorrow clean audio file
will be available immediately after
thank you very much everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this orchard originally was planted by
my grandfather 70 years ago today my
family God is just to keep it as green a
farm so people can come and visit and
see I want just used to be grown in
Israel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]